[Musique]
et quand famille ne pouvait dire on va
parler tout de suite de scènes de
ménages
onze ans de scènes de ménages est ce que
ça vous fait vraiment rire vous aimez
scènes de ménages tels que j'aime bien
avec les couples différents donc moi
vous savez les projets ou plaît oui bien
sûr c'est la différence d'âge ouais
ouais je pensais à très marrant je vais
faire un gros bisou à roger kay des
boîtes de nuit et sa souffrance moment
les je pense je pense à lui je pense à
tous les patrons de boîte de nuit qui
ont des problèmes en ce moment parce que
c'est c'est eh bien les scènes de ménage
11 ans fêtés toutes ses 11 ans en toute
discrétion rien vu dans scènes de
ménages ou away
ah oui je suis l'entraîneur de l'as du
cheval de gérard et un câble en mai
exactement déjà un an et c'est
exactement alors lancé en 2009 le
programme est très vite devenue l'une
des poules aux odeurs de la chaîne un
programme devenu plus qui passionne mais
qui interroge aussi car beaucoup
trouvent que l'humour et voilà c'est
voilà il y en a qui ça fait pas rire
j'aime bien personnellement et y en a
qui aiment pas regardez vous nous dites
juste après si vous comprenez le succès
de scènes de ménages
onze ans regardez c'est parti voilà
maintenant onze ans que le programme
court scènes de ménage fait les belles
heures de la chaîne m6 ah oui exact il
exact diffusé chaque jour à 20h35 depuis
2009 ce format a été librement adapté
par le producteur alain capa ou de la
série espagnole
kansas et matrimoniaux une série basée
sur le quotidien de plusieurs couples
d'âge différents qui sont censé raconter
la vie de france et à travers les âges à
j-9 pas spécialement des couples auquel
on espère ne jamais ressembler qui
suivent la série compte déjà douze
saisons à son actif et plus de 26000
épisode parmi les stars de ce programme
on retrouve bien entendu les meetings
raymond et huguette qui sont là depuis
la saison une jetée bleus filent le
coeur mais aussi josé et liliane les
quinquas relou les petits jeunes des
hauts et des semis qui remplace andré
lamy et loup-denis elion saperlipopette
ou encore philippe et camille qui ont
vingt ans d'écart j'ai bien compris ton
humour chage comprend des couples qui
attire en moyenne 4 millions de français
chaque foire et la case du 20h et
booster de 65%
une poule aux oeufs d'or pour m6 quand
on sait que la saison 2 a rapporté près
de 40 millions d'euros à la chaîne est
très bien merci
oui c est qui est depuis des années dans
le paysage audiovisuel et qu'il n'est
pas toujours facile de renouveler alors
11 ans de scènes de ménages est ce que
ça vous fait vraiment rire vous nous
guidiez voilà je vous donne une petite à
une petite info sachez qu'il ya trente
auteurs à l'origine de tous les sketchs
ils sont répartis en 3 ligue il ya
lalique 3c les débutants et à la ligne
de ses les jeunes pousses prometteuses
et à ligue 1 qui regroupe les auteurs
confirmés sassine d'infos rendez compte
trente auteurs nicolas pernikoff vous
vous comprenez le succès ce que ça vous
fait vraiment rire alors ça me fait pas
rire mais après c'est vrai que c'est une
superproduction ça c'est incroyable les
moyens qui sont mis sur ceux sur 7 j
adorais la passe donc moi ça ne sais pas
mais alors je suivais ça ne fait pas
marrer mais c'est l'humour c'est ultra
segmentant on a bien sûr un bon
il faut qu'on tourne en rond c'est
toujours un peu la même histoire on voit
toujours les coupes toucheront 10 alors
pour moi c'est pas le truc mais plus
drôle du monde mais par contre ça mérite
de détendre les gens et je pense que les
gens ont besoin de ça c'est d'être
détendu de regarder un truc qui portent
pas à réfléchir vous regardez ça pour
vous endormir pour faire une sieste
c'est épouvantable
jean michel lemaire c'est bien fait
c'est bien fait c'est bien produit c'est
souvent drôle voilà même si c'est sont
attendus parce que voilà on a tellement
la demande mon amitié au couple que ça
ronronne un peu mais je trouve surtout
j'attends d'une des plus grandes chaînes
qu'elle se renouvelle un peu 11 ans ils
ont mis des nouveaux coûts et aux
auteurs isabelle des fonds dès
maintenant
hier 4 millions c'est bah oui en pointe
à 5 millions alors dans le calme autour
alors moi j'avais comme je suis très
fier parce que j'avais convaincu gérard
landaise accepté au départ il voulait
pas le faire et je suis sûr que ça va
marcher
alors évidemment qu'il ya des coups
plomb qu'on préfère moi par exemple les
deux petits jeunes bercy culpabiliser
mais bon parce qu'elles aiment et ce
qu'ils disent mais sinon couple et ont
l'habitude de 2 du jeu de théâtre de
boulevard comme les deux plus vieux ou
les quinquas ils sont formidables
c'est la fiction quotidienne n'a plus
regardé en france même quand il ya eu
des visiteurs avec la version rallongée
avec les usa il continue à faire des
pointes à 5 à 4 millions ils seront tous
est la série la plus forte et mieux que
nos chers voisins c'est le client ils se
renouvellent il ya 1600 guez fois donc
il ya eu chabal il ya eu galabru il ya
eu bouder il ya eu amel bent et
récemment la semaine dernière ils ont
fait un tournage
il va y avoir un des vrais ou marie donc
le mari de valérie karsenti qui sera
dans la fiction est donc une véritable
marée dans la bonne et moi et j'étais
dit fréquemment il rigolait surtout
qu'il y avait le nouveau couple roulait
par terre mais je trouve que c'est
plaisant c'est rigolo ça détend comme
dit kelly et tout et puis je voulais
profiter pour aussi souhaiter
l'anniversaire à mon petit-fils d'accord
avec loic
beineix leader ses téléspectateurs ce
qu'on a d'autres sujets les chéris la
misère on veut juste dire que c'était
les onze ans 55% disent que ça l'était
vraiment rire 45%
non